Transcriptor: Mauro Costantino
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Muy buenas tardes.
Hoy quiero hablarles un poco de lo
que para mí es el secreto de la felicidad.
Me considero una persona sumamente
afortunada porque estoy feliz y soy feliz
y creo que es importante poder,
incluso, transmitir esto.
La cosa es que a veces,
muchas veces la gente
habla de felicidad
sin saber bien qué es.
Y hoy día vamos a ver, que para mí
la felicidad es una cosa muy sencilla
y se puede, incluso, resumir
hablando de cuatro puntos.
De verdad que, hoy día va a ser muy
sencillo, no vamos a hablar de autoayuda,
no vamos a hablar de pensamiento positivo,
vamos a hablar de lo que, para mí,
es el secreto de la felicidad.
Los cuatros puntos de que vamos
a hablar hoy día son muy sencillos.
Vamos a hablar de la diferencia entre
hacer bien las cosas y hacer cosas buenas.
Vamos a hablar de alcanzar los sueños,
vamos a hablar de la educación
y, finalmente, vamos a hablar
de cambiar el mundo.
Y es algo muy importante, yo creo,
empezar con la diferencia entre
hacer bien las cosas y hacer cosas buenas.
La cosa es que, no sé para Uds.,
pero para mí ha sido
desde niño siempre el mismo refrán.
Y la cosa es que toda la sociedad,
la familia, los compañeros te dicen
que tienes que hacer bien las cosas.
Y te lo dicen todos, ¿no? Te dicen:
"Tienes que hacer bien las cosas
en la escuela para ser un buen alumno,
tienes que hacer bien las cosas
en la familia, para ser un buen chico,
en el trabajo".
Y al final yo estaba en mi doctorado
y me esforzaba, me esforzaba mucho,
día y noche, trabajaba todo el día,
todos los días para hacer las cosas bien.
Y nunca se acababa, era una espiral
y me ha costado mucho, de verdad,
he llegado casi hasta el punto
de abandonar sobre todo el último año.
¡Era una cosa increíble!
Había que hacer bien las cosas,
había que hacer bien las cosas.
Hasta la cosa de "hacer bien"
era prácticamente el objetivo.
Y uno, uno a veces no se da cuenta, pero
es así, para mí fue muy útil conocer
a un docente, un docente que he conocido
a través de una charla virtual como el TED
aunque no conocía todavía el TED
en ese momento.
Ese docente era Randy Pausch del Carnegie
Mellon College de Norteamérica
y él me ha explicado que hay
una muy importante diferencia
entre hacer bien las cosas
y hacer cosas buenas.
Porque solo hacer bien las cosas,
si no te paras un minuto
para entender qué cosa estás haciendo,
bueno quizás no valga la pena.
Porque "hacer bien las cosas"
¿qué significa?
Puedes estafar a un amigo muy bien,
puedes cometer el delito perfecto
y has hecho muy bien la cosa,
puedes robar algo maravillosamente,
has hecho las cosas bien
y entonces me di cuenta de que
esta cosa de hacer bien las cosas
no es lo más importante,
tenemos que decidir qué hacer
y las cosas que tenemos que hacer
tienen que ser cosas buenas,
tienen que valer la pena,
porque ahí está todo el chiste.
En el momento en que yo puedo
cambiar la perspectiva
y ver que no es el esfuerzo el objetivo.
El objetivo no es "hacer bien las cosas"
esforzate, esforzate, esforzate...
porque si el esfuerzo
es el objetivo, nunca termina.
Nunca podrá terminar porque cada vez
hay un esfuerzo,
mientras que la cosa importante
es hacer las cosas buenas.
Y bueno, cuando empiezo a hacer
las cosas buenas, quizás no soy un genio,
quizás la primera vez
que hago algo me equivoco
habrá tropezones, habrá problemas
y sin embargo vale la pena.
Y si estoy haciendo cosas buenas,
también vale la pena el esfuerzo.
Vale la pena no dormir,
vale la pena meterle más,
vale la pena trabajar el fin de semana
porque el esfuerzo es un medio,
no es el objetivo.
Y entonces de esta manera
tiene mucho más sentido,
ya no es el esfuerzo por el esfuerzo
sino que puedo simplemente
concentrarme en las cosas buenas
y de ahí podemos dar el siguiente paso;
el siguiente paso es que si voy a hacer
las cosas buenas y el esfuerzo
no es el objetivo, ¿entonces?
Entonces puedo alcanzar mis sueños.
Y bueno, eso de alcanzar los sueños
a veces parece un poco [utópico]
incluso muchos colegas me dicen
que soy soñador,
pero es algo muy importante
y muy sencillo.
¿Cuál es el problema
de alcanzar los sueños?
El problema de alcanzar los sueños es que
este milenio, y sobre todo su milenio,
la post-modernidad nos ha dicho
que está mal,
nos ha dicho que está mal
alcanzar los sueños
porque son ilusiones,
porque no lo vas a alcanzar,
porque te esfuerzas por nada.
Incluso se puede entender, ¿no?
Este milenio viene después de un siglo
con muchos problemas, con guerras,
con temas donde era muy difícil
alcanzar los sueños.
Pero lo que pasa es que la sociedad
les dice que no vale la pena
alcanzar los sueños.
y más bien la sociedad,
el post-modernismo, les dice:
"¿Sabes qué? En vez de alcanzar
los sueños, ¡compra cosas!"
Puedes comprar cosas, porque
los sueños no los vas a alcanzar
pero puedes comprar un celular nuevo,
puedes comprarte ropa, puedes acumular
y ahí estamos con el problema
porque este milenio nos ha dicho que
no podemos alcanzar los sueños
y podemos sustituirlos con cosas.
El problema es que las cosas se rompen,
la ropa pasa de moda y, al final del día,
nos quedamos
con muy poca gente al rededor.
Y bueno, eso es un problema,
es un problema porque
los sueños vale la pena alcanzarlos y
porque la felicidad no está en las cosas.
Cuando me han preguntado si podía dar esta
charla, en realidad yo le he dicho que
quien debería dar esta charla
es mi perrita,
mi perrita ha entendido perfectamente
lo que es la felicidad.
Mi perrita sabe lo que es ser feliz.
Mi perrita ha entendido
que es muy sencillo.
La "Ley de la Lola", ella es,
es su nombre, nos dice que
se necesitan tres cosas para
estar feliz; ¿qué necesitamos?
Lola sabe que para estar feliz necesito
un techo bajo el cual dormir,
un plato lleno de croquetas
y alguien que me rasque la panza;
y con esto yo puedo estar feliz.
Y no estoy diciendo que no me gustan las
cosas, no estoy diciendo que no me gustan
los regalos, no estoy diciendo
que no me gusta comprar cosas.
Obviamente, no seamos hipócritas.
A todos le gusta.
Si me regalan cosas, fantástico,
las uso, lo que estoy diciendo es que
las cosas no son el sustituto
de la felicidad.
Y una vez que han entendido,
como lo ha entendido la Lola
que estas cosas pueden ser buenas,
pero no me dan la felicidad,
entonces pueden trabajar con los sueños.
Y lo que me hizo pensar
y entender de verdad lo que
era el trabajo con los sueños,
fue una figura muy importante en mi vida,
una figura que para mí ha sido, incluso,
acompañándome un buen trecho de mi vida.
La cosa es que yo, antes de entender
este tema de alcanzar los sueños
hacía lo que hacen todos los estudiantes
y los jóvenes: me quejaba.
Me quejaba de cualquier cosa.
Me quejaba de los horarios.
Me quejaba de la universidad,
me quejaba de los docentes,
me quejaba de los exámenes,
porque nos gusta mucho quejarnos.
Nos da gusto. Incluso nos juntamos
entre amigos, y nos quejamos.
A quién se queja más.
"Es que mi profe", "No pero el mío".
Como si tuviéramos a quién se puede quejar
más; es una cosa que hacemos todos.
Y obviamente lo hacía también yo.
Lo hacía tanto que casi no me daba cuenta.
La persona que pudo hacerme dar cuenta
fue mi abuela, la que pueden ver aquí.
Mi abuela hubiera querido estudiar,
siempre me ha contado mi abuela
que cuando era niña
soñaba con ser maestra.
Después hubo cambios en la vida,
hubo problemas, algunas situaciones,
una de esas situaciones fue la Segunda
Guerra Mundial, por ejemplo,
y entonces mi abuela no pudo estudiar.
Y no pudo aprender para ser maestra.
Sin embargo, mi abuela pudo aprender
a escuchar y escuchaba muy, muy bien.
Escuchaba tan bien, incluso
a su nieto que cada fin de semana
volvía de la universidad y se quejaba.
Media hora. Una hora. Quejándose.
Y bueno, mi abuela me escuchaba
y me dejaba desahogarme,
y un día, cuando justo estaba ahí
y ella estaba limpiando
sus verduras para la sopa del mediodía
y yo con mi queja de que los horarios,
de que los exámenes, de que
los profes, etcétera, etcétera,
me dejó hablar, hablar hasta cuando ya
no tenía quejas y sin ni siquiera mirarme
seguía simplemente limpiando sus verduras,
me comentó y me dijo:
"Bueno, de verdad que te creo,
debe ser muy, muy difícil
desenvolverse en la universidad.
Mira, ni siquiera me lo puedo imaginar,
debe ser muy, muy complicado
ser un estudiante universitario.
Fíjate que tu abuelo,
cuando tenía tu edad,
estaba en un campo
de concentración alemán.
Y bueno, esta cosa, me puso
un poquito en perspectiva.
Porque, finalmente, bueno yo quizás tenía
problemas con los horarios de las clases
y un profesor que no me caía bien.
Pero ahí me di cuenta de que finalmente
a mí nadie me había obligado.
Nadie me había obligado a inscribirme
en la universidad,
nadie me había obligado
a estudiar japonés,
a tomar esos horarios y trabajar.
Más bien yo estaba,
y no me estaba dando cuenta,
yo estaba siguiendo mis sueños,
estaba justo trabajando para mis sueños.
Y bueno, era difícil, ¡sí! Y bueno
significaba trabajar en las noches, sí.
Pero finalmente yo no me había
dado cuenta hasta ese momento,
que decenas y centenares de personas,
habían luchado, habían sufrido,
y habían muerto, para que yo pueda
escoger, para que yo pueda decidir,
para que yo pueda hacer
lo que quería hacer.
Muchas generaciones
no habían tenido esa suerte.
Yo podía escoger qué hacer,
podría escoger qué camino tomar,
podía trabajar para mis sueños.
Y eso era gracias a personas como ella.
Y fue muy importante para mí entenderlo
y me puso de nuevo
un poco en la perspectiva.
Porque al final había entendido
que sí, podía trabajar para mis sueños.
Y que sí, valía la pena.
Aunque sea por respeto hacia
las personas que habían luchado
para darme esta oportunidad.
Y ahí, ahí estaba ya
un muy buen paso adelante.
Estaba muy cerca de
lo que es la felicidad.
Incluso estaba seguro de estar feliz.
Tuve que trabajar y encontrar una persona
más para entender el siguiente paso.
Porque hay un siguiente paso.
Porque realizar tus sueños
te hace muy feliz,
pero hay algo más que
te puede hacer más feliz.
Esta persona para mí fue muy importante
y fue mi profesora durante el doctorado.
La Dra. Carla Marello que un día mientras
estaba en la oficina del doctorado
sacó su silla, se sentó frente de mí,
me miró y dijo:
"Costantino, ¿Ud. qué quiere hacer
cuando sea grande?"
Y bueno fue una sorpresa porque
un poquito grande me sentía
estaba en un doctorado, o sea...
y sin embargo...
y sin embargo fue una pregunta
muy importante,
porque yo estaba haciendo
algo que me gustaba,
estaba siguiendo mis sueños
pero no había pensado qué
quería hacer cuando sea grande,
porque, como todos, había
entrado a la universidad
y no sabía lo que venía después.
Y eso me hizo pensar que
me encantaba estudiar idiomas,
me encantaba aprender
de sus culturas nuevas,
me encantaba el contacto
con nuevas poblaciones, lugares,
conocer, hablar idiomas nuevos,
conocer culturas nuevas.
Y entonces quizás había algo muy
importante que me podía hacer feliz.
Ahí entendí una cosa sumamente
importante, hay solo una cosa
que te permite de ser más feliz
que alcanzar tus sueños
y es permitir que los otros
alcancen sus propios sueños.
Ahí he decidido dedicarme
a la educación, a la enseñanza,
porque finalmente he pensado:
"Si a mi tanto me gusta,
debe haber gente en el mundo
que tiene el mismo deseo,
debe haber gente que quiere
estudiar idiomas y aprender
entonces yo puedo ser ese medio,
para que ellos alcancen sus sueños.
Y, de verdad, que es el pasito final
para alcanzar tu felicidad.
Porque al final del día, es muy importante
eso; tú puedes alcanzar tus sueños,
pero si das un paso más y permites
a las personas a tu rededor
que alcancen sus sueños, ahí
puedes conseguir algo importante.
¿Y es difícil? ¡Claro! Es difícil, pero
este punto ya sabemos que vale la pena
porque muchos colegas me dicen
que soy un soñador, que es irreal,
pero al final del día,
cuando has saltado tus almuerzos
porque te estás esforzando, pero no por
el esfuerzo, sino por unos sueños,
cuando has decidido que las cosas
que estás haciendo son buenas
y vale de verdad la pena dejar
tu familia al otro lado del océano,
vale la pena trabajar todo
el fin de semana,
vale la pena saltar los almuerzos,
vale la pena dedicarte 100 %.
Si has decidido esto, al final
del día, tú sabes de las ojeras,
que estás despeinado, que estás cansado
pero has dado un granito de arena más.
Y quizás mañana no estaremos
en un mundo perfecto.
Quizás la próxima semana no estaremos
en el país de las maravillas
pero sabemos, si hemos dedicado
el día a hacer algo bueno,
que estamos dando un poquito,
un paso adelante,
aunque sea poco,
mañana será mejor que hoy día.
Estamos caminando
hacia un mundo más humano
y esto es lo que vale la pena
y esto es el secreto de la felicidad.
[Te envío esta foto para que recuerdes
a quien tanto te ama] Gracias.
(Aplausos)